[Música]
antes mas eu gostava de agradecer o
convite de estar aqui hoje
nota por pela melhoria das pensões
sociais que estão entusiasmadíssimos com
a minha apresentação
obrigada pai e hoje vai falar vos de
pessoas que estão no ensino superior
alguns calhar até já trabalham quem é
que já trabalha com outros terão em
breve no mercado trabalho original tirar
um ano sabático para procurar novas
perspectivas de vida e de fato o
trabalhar em empresas estarmos em
organizações tem muito que se lhe diga e
é por aí que eu crio deixar vos aqui não
consegue isso até porque os conselhos
fossem bons vendiam-se não estavam
mas aquilo que são as minhas
experiências ao longo de 26 anos apoiar
pessoas e trabalhar com pessoas nas
organizações e de fato aqui uma coisa
que é muito importante que é o poder do
relacionamento interpessoal é forma como
nós nos relacionamos com os outros
porque enquanto andamos na faculdade e
também já acontece
agora temos que ter a noção quando vamos
para buscar trabalho
vamos encontrar pessoas diferentes com
diferentes tipos de personalidade
perspectivas de forma de estar na vida e
sempre tanto nós percebemos esse método
respeitarmos o programa primeiro grande
príncipe buscar trabalho do
relacionamento interpessoal é
efetivamente o respeito os pais pelo
próprio grupo nós próprios em primeiro
lugar e de seguida por todas as pessoas
com quem nós temos que o selecionado e
hoje podem implicar que o trânsito há um
que é acima de tudo não esquecemos que
independentemente de tudo aquilo que
seja opiniões não um que são contrários
aquilo que é a nossa opinião acima tudo
devemos respeitá-la devemos aceitá los
concordando ou não com elas e é porque
eu gostava de começar ou seja acima tudo
deve ser o que o universo líderes querem
de nós próprios
e como é que se é líder nós próprios
perguntou vocês
não houve nada
isso produziu a vocês é saber ser saber
estar acima de tudo e aqui vamos buscar
um crime aquilo que são as contas e
competência que também já foram faladas
aqui ao nível do ensino superior e até a
ouro percurso escolar por assim dizer
nós temos fato trabalhamos aqui as
competências consoante aquilo que são os
nosso a nossa vocação
depois há um conjunto de competências
que nós temos trabalhar e que estão
relacionadas obviamente com a liderança
em termos de recebermos trabalhar em
equipa saber os cheiros e clientes
e isto ser resiliente aprendermos
efetivamente com as vicissitudes da vida
e nós tivemos aqui já hoje alguns
testemunhos de pessoas que conseguiram
dar a volta com situações menos
favoráveis ou menos agradáveis da vossa
vida da nossa vida o que acha e pesto de
nós pensamos o que vem por aí
e para isso é importante que façamos
outra coisa que é tenhamos uma
perspectiva que em termos de resolução
de problemas e conflitos nós somos
capazes de resolver porque infelizmente
nós temos no mundo onde a maioria das
pessoas passa a vida que lamentar se não
consigo não sou capaz e sem possível diz
que só isso não é pra nós
e será que a cimpor concluiu que a
espécie não é claro não é para mim
existem efetivamente dois grandes tipos
pessoas que são o que eu digo é que as
pessoas que eu encontro nas organizações
temos por um ato os senhores ou senhoras
problemas e quem são estas pessoas
porque são não consigo não são capazes é
um problema eu chamo dos consultores de
problemas ou seja perante um problema é
arranjar mais três ou quatro problemas
concordam
muito vai e numa outra perspectiva
temos os senhores ou senhoras funções
concordam e quem são essas pessoas são
aquelas pessoas que tem plena noção da
realidade a realidade é essa
vai sempre
conflitos que vai sempre ter problemas
que vai sempre trazer novos desafios
para os quais nós não estávamos à espera
não estávamos em contato
são pessoas que conseguem de alguma
forma vara volta eo que era volta para
volta é tão simples quanto durante
aquilo que são as instituições
conhecidas da nossa zona fogem da nossa
zona de conforto nós temos a capacidade
e humildade e hombridade de arregaçar
mangas e dizer eu sou capaz
nós somos capazes concordam sem e para
isso nós temos que ter objetivos bem
definidos bem definidos bem claros com
delicioso em propósitos que tem
propósito propósitos vira tentarem toda
a gente tá bom então eu vou ensinar vos
aqui uma técnica que em conjunto com que
o juliano disso pode trazer que algumas
van
vantagens que é chamada técnica pp ce é
quem conhece aqui duas pessoas que
conhecem a vencer porque eu não vou
dizer que será a técnica que o pse é a
partir do momento em que nós temos um
propósito e queremos algo para nós é
importante que nós nos focos nesse mesmo
propósito
e esse propósito acima de tudo deve ser
encarado como um desafio como algo que
somos capazes ou crimes muito e que ao
concretizar os seus membros pessoas num
cadinho melhores profissionais um crime
jorge e muito mais
concretizados por assim dizer ah isso é
importante perceber que nem todos os
propósitos que nós temos são
concretizáveis numa primeira fase
veja às vezes nós temos que contornar as
situações
aliás eu costumo dizer e com as pessoas
que me conhecem sabem que quando o plano
a não funcionar o alfabeto tem mais 23
letras ele acha neste momento em mais 26
com o novo acordo ortográfico tanto
plano a não funciona você
o plano e se vê é e depois de termos
todas as combinações possíveis
a mãe portanto neste momento que o chope
é que vocês pensem num propósito ou seja
pensa no propósito não precisa dizer
parcelar todos num propósito algo que
eram muito concretizar fox nisso estão
focados
sim muito focados só assim nesta altura
do dia em que toda a gente possa montar
essa chuva toda a gente focada no
propósito e neste momento vamos fazer
posição super-homem ou supermulher
preparados
a técnica que ps eram significa que
quero não posso consigo e preço cai
então pensando no vosso propósito faça o
favor de cocares nesse mesmo propósito e
ligam em voz baixa só em pensamento eu
quero eu posso eu consigo eo preço
eu quero eu posso eu consigo e eu mereço
agora vou desafiar o seu terceiro êxito
em alta voz pode ser lá em 3.1 eu quero
eu
qualquer semelhança com com algum ritual
num grande questão não tem nada a ver
com isso não foram suficientemente
convincentes em outros mesmo em 3 a 2
uai
muito vai mas salva de palmas por vocês
boa podem sentar podem sentar
olha aqui uma questão quem torce e às
vezes as pessoas perguntam que ao se ver
mas como é que nós conseguimos estar
sempre aqui o que é estar aqui não é nem
sempre nós conseguimos ficar dias
melhores a dias piores
há dias em que estamos com mais energia
dias que estamos comendo cirurgia
o que eu sugiro que vocês façam a
catarina falou que muito nisso
ela dizia partir do momento em que mudou
a forma de pensar a vida começou a
correr melhor é eu queria impor e
naturalmente todos nós vamos ter dias
assim
não sou capaz disto isto é impossível
não eu não vou conseguir fazer isto
a partir do momento em que nós sentimos
o qual se sentem que efetivamente estão
num dia menos bom cujos dias não estão é
o rubro por como eu costumo dizer apenas
uma pequena pergunta deve fazer a vocês
próprios e pequena pergunta é este
pensamento beneficia e qual vai ser a
resposta não então se o pensamento não
beneficia se esta forma de ser e de
estar não beneficia que eu tenho que
fazer
foca outro lado também e sim eu posso
ter que ultrapassar é que diferentes
obstáculos agora o vôo e efetivamente
trabalhar no sentido de usar o meu
melhor para chegar ao final do meu dia
com é consciência do dever cumprido
é isso não é certo o importante é que
você acha
tenho a noção de que podem ser melhores
a cada dia e nós temos a noção podemos
fingir ser melhor a cada dia e também
não se podendo a perfeição isso não
existe nem sequer funciona eu tenho um
professor na faculdade se esqueçam a
perfeição não há empresas perfeitas não
há pessoas perfeitas não há perfeição
por si só não funciona agora é que nós
podemos efetivamente fazer é é que devia
criar um chenot isso eu concordo em
pleno porque efetivamente a nossa
capacidade entre no time jorge em
trabalhar nos integrarmos das equipas em
crimes semelhantes
hoje isso vai fazer diferença entre nós
e aquelas pessoas que se resignou é
viver uma vida dita normal e paraíso eu
vou concluir como história e esta
história tem muito a ver com tudo que
foi dito é que ao longo do dia de hoje e
tv também obviamente o vosso futuro
auxiliar tinha duas filhas
viúvo e tem alguma dificuldade em lidar
com elas na cimpor gente traquinas e
sempre prontas para a aventura
certo dia e não sabendo o que fazer com
as suas filhas pra resolver eu levá las
até a aldeia onde vivia um sábio
as meninas procuraram de dar alguma
forma 363 para se divertirem enquanto
estava na aldeia
certo dia mais velha virou para a mais
nova e disse que tudo sabe saber tudo
não tem muito que se lhe diga eu acho
que sabe não sabe tudo sabe viver na
aldeia e por norma ajudava e concentrava
todas as pessoas da aldeia é com
dificuldade se irmana mas que quando as
pessoas vão lá toda a gente sabe tudo e
eu decidi dizer verdades vendola
satisfeitas pois mas eu não acredito
mais nisso que eu vou provar ou sabe o
que afinal eu não sabia tudo pode fazer
isso não sai deixando pensar e depois e
8 chegar a uma conclusão
pensou pensou pensou e dias depois ou
perder vai diz irmã já sei como é que
vamos treinar o sábio assim anda comigo
vamos apanhar borboleta depois o split e
assim foi
e quando ganharam as ruas suficientes
a mais velha disse para a mais nova
olha nós vamos louvar os borboletas
e vamos fazer uma pergunta
o sábio é que o que eu tenho na minha
mão o que nós temos na nossa mão está
vivo ou morto
se não sabe se é está vivo que nós
fazemos as palmas das mãos
abrimos as mãos e por vamos só sabe o
que o final do eta está morta e tem seu
dizer que ela está morta aí é fácil
aí veremos as mãos e por último a votar
vamos conseguir provar ao sábio que
efetivamente e eu não sabia tudo
assim quer então lá vamos lá for hoje
duas meninas a subir a montanha e quando
chegaram sabem se fizeram a mais velha
muito mais astuta disse
ou sabe o que é que nós temos na nossa
mal está vivo ou morto
o que vocês acham que o sábio respondeu
não sai mais dispostas
mas alguém tem mais festa o sábio
sabiamente responde em resposta à sua
pergunta está única e exclusivamente nas
tuas mãos
assim como o vosso futuro o nosso futuro
está única e exclusivamente nas nossas
mãos na forma como nós um dia crime
chico disse tite na forma como nós um
dia crimes contar a nossa história e por
quê porque acima de tudo cabe a cada um
nós escolher o melhor para que quando
chegarmos ao final da nossa missão olhos
para trás e digamos erechim eu queria
ser enquanto pessoa enquanto
profissional enquanto ser humano
e tudo isto porque por voz e chon futuro
obrigada
[Música]